[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm Rhett and
I'm link this week at the roundtable of
dim lighting we asked the question what
the crap happened to rets mom in
scotland a vacation this is a
continuation as you might be able to
tell if you're watching we literally are
continuing yes that's why link still has
an enema on the table the enema that
looks like a lollipop well let me tell
you brother from here on out on your
biscuits I'm always gonna have an enema
right here cuz as I'm establishing you
keep it in your pocket it's important to
me well I mean my pants are a bit of the
night I'd rather not you don't want to
you don't want to put an enema in a in a
high squeeze environment you know like a
pocket that's true so you want to keep
it a loose environment which I'll get to
in a moment a loose environment I mean
could you just it'll mix it so I yeah
I'm gonna tell the whole story of what
exactly happened to my mom and the
significance of that and there's quite a
lead-up so they'll be plenty we'll get
into that after the break
cuz we don't talk on vacation like our
wives they takes a little text a lot
back and forth and at one point either
Jesse or Christie started a text thread
with all four of us which I thought was
sweet and there was one day where I had
had a few beers and I started to I could
tell participate and I was the reason I
was not participating in the text Ernest
I was driving on the wrong side my left
side of the road the whole time and then
Jesse was just telling me what I was
saying
yeah Jesse just thought I was being
friendly and then you yeah she said that
you asked her to ask me if I had been
drinking yeah cuz I was like links I'm
like I'm on vacation what's with the
judgement it was not judgment it was
just Detective well you sent a picture
of a French man well no Jesse sent a
picture of you driving yeah and she said
look at what I'm next to or something
like that and I was like well look at
what I'm next to and I was like poolside
at my second location
up in Chiang Rai the northernmost
mountainous territory of Thailand I was
at mountainous resort that was also an
elephant sanctuary and to my left was a
guy from Paris who I took a picture of
and texted it to you because I had a few
beers yeah and I'll share it with all of
you right now if you're watching the
video here he is friendly guy oh you can
do that he's on his phone looking at
this video right now that's what the
picture is him on his phone looking at
himself in the ear biscuits video
version because Thai I die he doesn't
apply to Parisians they Eiffel Tower
above it that's a reach anyway yeah so
yeah that was my second stop was Chiang
Rai and oh boy this place I stayed at I
mean I was just pool side it's like a
infinity pool overlooking the river that
forms the boundary with Laos and Myanmar
the Golden Triangle right and I didn't
experience any of that some guy and I'd
look down there and something and his
way down it was like it was up on the
hill and then you look down there and it
was just like what I called the jungle
but it wasn't and um his elephants
freaking sanctuary two elephants in view
just live in their sanctuary lives
rescued from whatever questionable
activities they had to be doing
of course logging was outlawed they you
know using the they would use elephants
as tractors of course you know for the
longest time elephants were used in war
you know they've got two big elephants
you know you've seen Lord of the Rings
I've seen it a few times
well I'm not saying that that was the
Thai people I don't know who those
people were but they were fictitious
fictitious and they were on hue these
huge elephants like leading in the war I
went to the bar Thailand they freaking
ward on elephant here's a connection I
went to the bar where CS Lewis and
Tolkien would Tolkien meet really the
eagle it's called the eagle and the
something and it's in Oxford and we went
in there and it's like
quotes from from them on the walls and
stuff because it's like their bar they
would go and like hang out smoke pipes
and like discuss things really yeah
texts pictures of Parisians do yeah yeah
yeah yeah we got to spend some time with
elephants like getting to know the story
of where they're rescued from and how
they're taking care of and it's a
complicated situation the the elephant
economy of Thailand and trying to figure
out how how to do right by elephants
that were raised in captivity and also
to in the long term have have elephants
thrive in the wild as much as I will say
as much as humanly possible because you
know humans aren't gonna say oh well
this is the elephant's land I'm not
gonna have anything to do with this you
know it's like we're within within the
realm of humans how well can elephants
live right hopefully better and better
and sanctuaries like this are
contributing to the care of those that
are have been caught in the crossfire of
tourism ironically as a tourist I saw
and hosed off elephants so go figure
well they gotta be hosed off got a hose
them off in like they have a nose that's
a hose I mean humans got a government
okay yeah you man I'm not gonna argue
with you or anybody else about the
treatment of elephants I love elephants
they're very smart smarter than humans
yes but not dolphins no no no dolphins
are the smartest than Elvis than humans
um didn't have anything to do with
dolphins so much red so at least we
don't have to bring that in so we were
there at that resort also took a cooking
class one of the things that I saw I did
see that a lot of the people offer on
your wife's Esther Graham in Bangkok at
in Chiang Rai every way artists because
Thai cuisine is so famous and so unique
people want to learn how to cook it of
course I don't because I don't want to
learn how to cook anything right but I
find
self in the cooking class and I'm paired
up with Lando because he doesn't want to
be alone and I'm paired up with Lando
because I don't want to be alone like
I'm using I mean they actually gave me a
knife and I'm like cutting this you know
for a while they don't know huh you
don't know and then by the end of it
yeah it's like they knew
and so like Lando's using the knife it
is like I'd hold the knife and Landover
taking good and should be I made a pad
thai burned it Lando made a pad thai and
I ate it because it was good I by the
end of it I was kind of tired Thai food
because to us it's a special thing to
them it's their food right but we're
just not used to eating it all the time
the eagle and the child pub that was the
name of a thinking the name of that pub
you went yeah so we went there spent I
think five nights there that was it was
an amazing amazing place I went on an
excursion one morning into town and
spent an hour and a half going to every
place that could maybe have fiber with a
driver from the resort who barely spoke
English didn't find any
and I would Google Fiber and then he
would translate it and give it to the
person working at the FarmVille fiber
isn't that a thing something different
and the woman finally understood what I
was asking for and she came back with
more of these good yeah that's all you
really I have so many of these bulbs of
enemas now and then we went to cosas muy
and you know I'll just say that I was on
a hammock on a beach drinking out of a
coconut sounds like you relaxed quite a
bit I relaxed quite a bit I needed a
vacation from a vacation but I didn't
get that I got work the thing that had
the biggest impact I mean I'll never
forget Thailand I think at the end of
this whole thing I'll give a complete
conclusion about my vacation so I'll
save that but there was one thing that I
think changed my life in the most
practical sense as a result of this trip
and it was something I got a little
souvenir
it's not another enema is this hmm
fanny pack now is fanny pack has a
snapchat logo on it because I got it for
free
I I you know that was the only way you
didn't I got it in a VidCon like two
weeks before we left for vacation
and because I'm I'm too much I got too
much pride to actually buy a fanny pack
and you know what I'm sorry for that I
realized the error of my ways there is
nothing better when traveling than a
fanny pack I mean especially if you got
five people's passports you got two
different kinds of legal tender you've
got a wallet you got a phone
you got lip balm you've got sunglasses
in a sunglasses case so you did a full
transfer man I can't live without this
I'm back in the real world I'm off
vacation and I can't stop using this
thing okay well this is a good time for
me to interject it I also used a fanny
pack throughout my entire vacation
really somebody actually I got a picture
with somebody now I wore it across the
chest as opposed to cross that's the
chest a fanny you tell them out a chest
pack no it's a fanny pack attaced you
can wear it multiple places you can wear
now it's cool because they sell them in
Urban Outfitters for the kids now I got
warrant I bought one over a year ago
when I knew I was gonna go to Scotland
and I got one that packs I got like I
got a fanny pack that packs down to like
that size and a whole backpack that
packs down its Matador I think is the
brand I got a packable and and so I
ended up using both depending on what
the what the day was but somebody
criticized my placement of the pack and
that it was up here but a little too
high I kind of like the dorky way to
play a guitar I feel like the wearing it
around the belt did some weird things
with my midsection and it was already
have a belt yeah I had to figure out how
to do it enables a French tuck of sorts
I don't believe in that you know your
freedom fries I'm with the Parisians now
I beg with Parisians and I wear a fanny
pack with the French tuck but I
I ended up using it because the passport
thing like you said like it was great
for security and everything like having
to reach for all that but the and I
don't know it'll for what it was like in
Thailand but in the UK they still use
coinage a lot oh really
for like parking for using the bathroom
and you're in public like you got to
have coins for tolls so I had a lot of
coinage in there mmm
it's good for that but I kept my phone
and my wallet in my back pockets because
I wanted to the quicker access nothing
is quicker than the fanny pack access if
you have it properly placed a zipper
there's no zipper on my pocket yeah okay
pickpockets big yeah I didn't have to
worry about a big thing where I was so
it's like you want if somebody takes
your whole thing you're screwed I am
screwed yeah you got to diversify it's
like a portfolio you got to have
something in another pie have a lock on
my I have a lockable fanny pack I could
get that off of you I don't have a lock
I was lying anyway but so are you
you couldn't get it off of me he fit had
a lock I bet I could pull hard enough
pair of scissors pull hard enough
Pierce's cut a sentence I'm just going
through the ways I could take a fanny
pack off a man why enough pair of
scissors explosive device I think I can
nicely pull hard enough I think I could
stay right with porn and get a Fame just
about anybody I'm willing to put on this
fanny pack have you pull hard enough see
what happened okay can I use my other
hand to press the button to get it
well that's what they would do a picture
lock you can easily just take that off
and then you're right they have it well
this is funny because I did I thought as
I was coming back am i gonna transfer
this to my everyday life in America and
I have it well listen and I thought I
wasn't either I come what are you
keeping in there now put the fanny pack
down and I put I put I started taking my
stuff out and then we have to go to the
grocery store Lilly's like let's go to
the grocery store and get some stuff
because you know we need some stuff mom
made a list I'm like great I got to make
sure I got everything for my smoothie
and that fiber and we get there we get
to the checkout and I'm like I'll be
damned
I don't have my wallet I'll be damned
with a D at the end but I'm not good at
cursing once we started doing it on your
business oh man I got to figure out how
to curse you just fed right into a can
you keep my groceries so I can go home
and get my wallet I usually would have
any my fanny pack that's what I've been
doing for the past two weeks but I
didn't think I could do fanny pack back
here in America and he's like yeah so
I'll go home and I get my wallet I put
it in my pocket and I come back and I'm
like I still missed the fanny bag
because I'm like when I walked in to the
grocery store I had on my regular
glasses not my sunglasses because I had
to leave my sunglasses in the car but if
I had my fanny pack see where you're
going but I see where you're going with
this
this is nice how I am it's not
sustainable I like to have everything
with me at all times I'm not sustain the
green lip balm I could probably fit like
a little flask of water it's not
sustainable because it drastically
impacts your overall look it's a giant
pack that you've secured to yourself but
isn't it cool down yeah but are you
gonna go you gotta go to a party with a
fanny pack on you don't go to parties I
go to the grocery store I'm gonna go to
war to go to a get-together with I got a
pack on fanny packs are for travel I I
just I just believe they're for travel
or maybe four days out like I'm going
out for the day when I need this stuff I
went to get together with our friends
and I have my fanny pack on what wait
you think somebody would it become no no
no I'm not saying that I'm saying that
there we do reason I wouldn't do it is
because it's like whether you wear it
across the chest or around the fanny
to me it's like it's it's an accessory
that does more than like a purse a purse
is something I can hang it on my
shoulder then I can set it down or hang
it hearse no I'm saying I think a man
purse makes more sense than a fanny pack
this is a Seinfeld episode there was a
man-purse episode well I don't know what
the conclusion was yeah well it's 2019 I
mean man purses are like kind of a thing
for a lot of men at this point great and
I'm saying the reason I don't have a man
purse
first of all I have a backpack so if I
if there's things like my name my laptop
or whatever I wear my backpack but the
the only thing I really need are my
wallet and my phone I need keys
sunglasses lip balm flask of water you
need more than I do
perhaps a paper map folded cargo pants
man
now obviously cargo pants are also stuff
you know yeah I'm just saying you if you
commit to that you're like you're gonna
go to like a formal event and now you've
become dependent upon a fanny pack like
what are you gonna do on it's a formal
event you you don't want to go to a
formal event with a guy with a fanny
pack that's definitely that's true but I
don't think you do either
no I would be the guy I'd be going with
myself okay well we could continue this
discussion later we I mean it I don't
know if we've come to any conclusions I
think if we say they're great for travel
I think what would I think what would
tip the scales for you is if we sold a
mythical fanny pack I think we should
sell a mythical fanny pack I believe in
them as a as an item and I used it to
great effect on my vacation but then I
life is a vacation Rhett but then I just
made the decision that this is not
practical like I don't need my 360
camera but I can carry stuff for you
okay that's all that to change your mind
okay we like I don't want to do a whole
episode about a face like a book of
matches that's all I'm gonna care for
you like matches okay it matches it all
I think very very ever read the little
match girl matches are useful she had
one more match he probably did not be
dead spoiler alert
but first oh you know what we got a new
item a new item we're very excited about
you've seen us wear blindfolds you've
slept before well now there is a
blindfold slash sleep mask available at
mythical calm you can get it in the red
style or the link style or both sleep
with it on a plane sleep with it in your
bed if you're sleeping with lights on I
have it all over my headphone so it
probably fits a little interestingly use
it when doing blind taste test at your
home you really can't see
think I mean I can't see anything I
can't see out the bottom top side
nothing if you want people to feed you
nuggets or other types of foods for you
to identify you can do that now with the
official rhett and Link blindfold sleep
mask available at mythical calm as well
as other stuff
TBD fanny packs I'm fully behind selling
a fanny pack
let me just make that clear okay I'm
gonna tell the story about my mom I do
want to I was kind of thinking about
what I what I talked about in the first
episode about our vacations and just
realized that it kind of made it seem
like I haven't done anything on my
vacation you ov horribly I I went a lot
of different places
your hair looks nuts right now I think
you should go with that though that's
good is it bad he's like his life I want
like a lane from scientist flat and good
it's good I saw a lot of amazing things
I actually I played golf with my dad and
my brother one of the things that I've
been wanting to do for a long time was
be able to give the gift of playing golf
at st. Andrews the the birthplace of
golf to my father that's the city of st.
Andrews right on having a good time each
McGlothlin has one hole to their names
one one one and we were able to do that
Wow didn't play the old course because
it was completely booked even months
ahead of time but played one of the
courses the castle course played match
play against each other for those of you
know what that is
makes it more fun especially when you're
you suck at golf which works we're
actually all pretty good it off but you
know not good enough to take on this
course and be have a respectable
respectable score but we had a great
time like I said I've stopped an Oxford
for the day saw what I believe is the
it's what every college campus in every
college town aspires to be but it will
never even approach like it's just
fascinating history everywhere and it
was really an incredible vacation as
much as it was a lot all packed into a
very short period of time and as much as
I felt like I was
not getting to really experience anyone
location as much as I wanted to or could
if I chose to it was a great time but
something happened okay okay so one of
the things that I had been really I
think was the you know I know with you
it was your dad saying thigh food for me
it was a little deeper it was the idea
that I had this romantic idea that I
wanted to take all the McLaughlin's to
Scotland as this sort of like let's go
to the home country kind of trip and I
had I knew that there was a through just
very brief cursory research I knew that
there was a Lachlan castle which was
basically where it started with you know
Lachlan son of Lachlan is McLaughlin and
all that stuff and so I was like and I'd
looked years ago I had seen on the
internet that hey there's still a
Lachlan castle and there's still a chief
of the McLaughlin clan and did you do
some sort of family tree situation or is
it just no I don't you basically I know
so I guess of that that's that's where
that name came from right kind of know
so and I'll get into a little bit more
of the history in a second but I tried
using ancestry.com not a sponsor to
trace back my family and basically on
both sides of my family you can get back
to about the 1700s and it's just some
you know what seems to be just like sort
of like a poor like farmer somewhere
that it wasn't wealthy enough to have
good records and you there's no father
or a mother listed for them so with them
there it gets back to a guy named Edward
McLaughlin who was born in 1822 in
Pennsylvania and no known father okay so
it's like okay Edward as far back as I
can go and then like on the Cowen side a
mom side basically about the same time
you get back to the 1800s and so not
very far at all like I've not been able
to defend
trace myself to the McLaughlin clan but
I was like ah doesn't really matter you
know I mean I can't do it but I'm a
McGlothlin and when you go look at
Lachlan clan on Wikipedia it says our
McLaughlin it says like alternative
pronunciations or Spelling's in
mcLaughlin spelled my way is one of them
so I'm like okay it's good enough but
it's really more about the the event of
like getting this group of people
together that we've never been on
vacation together like I have not
vacationed with my brother and my
parents since we did vacations as kids
and mica my oldest nephew is going into
a senior year in high school so I was
like this might be the last time that
we're all available to just like go on a
trip together and I just had this idea
like it'll be fun to go over there we'll
go meet the the chief will get kilts
we'll take pictures family photo and
that'll be make it all worth it now so
we're in the process of working out the
details in order to make what I just
described happen and one of the things I
was concerned about is my mom has become
less mobile over the past you know she's
getting older uh and so she's become
less mobile and I knew that going over
to I mean it's a she's still walking
everything but she's just walking more
slowly and you know steps and long
distances and that kind of thing becomes
sort of a concern so I I knew that going
to a country as old you know
civilization as old as Scotland was you
know that it's not like they've there's
a bunch of ramps and stuff around I mean
we're talking about castles we're
talking about stone steps that are not
up to modern day codes okay so I knew
there'd be a lot of walking and so what
I did and I think I talked about this
but I bet I got her a trainer back in
North Carolina somebody who can meet
with her and basically help her work out
and get stronger and get her legs
stronger and that kind of thing so she'd
been doing that for
seven or eight months leading up to the
trip she was that she was open to that
she was cool with that yeah I mean it
took it took a little bit of talking her
into it but then she did it and then I
mean she loved it and she would I talked
on the phone and she would say I'm
having a great time with my trainer even
the trainer kind of like switched in the
middle because this one woman left and
she got like a guy came in but she's
like I love my trainer I love what I'm
doing I'm getting stronger I'm feeling
good sometimes when a trainer switches
you don't even notice like using that
magic trick which like the trainer
switch a guy can kind of David Blaine
David Blaine they did that and become a
different person and you won't even
notice yeah Criss Angel maybe I think
was that redheaded more magician on
YouTube I don't know about him he's the
guy I'm interested so I you know we get
there and I I said earlier that the the
forecast was rain basically every day
and we experienced a lottery in the
first day but then it kind of cleared up
and it would rain a little bit but we
had all the sunlight that we needed to
do the things that we had planned for
each day I kind of had like a thing that
we were gonna do every day you know we
saw an bura which all the castle we took
a tour of the the Mary Kings close which
is basically like how they built the
city over the centuries and you can go
down and like my mom took all these
steps and she kept coming up to me she's
like I couldn't have done this without
that training that I've been doing hmm
she had me she kept coming up to me and
just saying that like this has been so
helpful how God wouldn't be doing this
and and then we go to Glencoe and we do
a day a falconry falconry I got a guy
did too and this Hawk name Elsa that we
all got to spend time with and she would
fly off and then we'd put some chicken
on her hand she would come and fly back
and eat it everybody did it when I was
at Koh Samui I went to a Falcon
sanctuary where they don't make them do
that anymore
just kidding she seemed to be happy
and so and also on that day we were
supposed to get rain and it didn't rain
I was like this is just going so well
like everything is going well
oh yeah the weather's great and then the
next day your credit yeah yeah the next
day we're gonna go and we're the plan is
we're gonna go down to we're gonna drive
like an hour or so south of Glencoe
we're gonna go to the old Lachlan Castle
we're gonna meet the chief of the clan
yes we're gonna hang out with him for a
little bit and then we're gonna go to
maybe knock back a few we're gonna meet
a photographer Paul what's his name and
he's going to oh we're gonna get into
full garb kilts basically no bagpipes
involved and we were gonna try to do the
mclaughlin tartan because every family
has their own tartan but they couldn't
didn't have enough we used like just a
general like scotland millenium tartan
she looked very Scottish tartan just a
pattern or is it a flag it's a path it's
a pattern it's basically what we would
just dumb rednecks will call plaid yeah
it's a special plan it's a type of plaid
man okay and and every family has their
own you go into these shops that are all
around Scotland it's like either here's
all the families all the clans and
here's their special tartan and it's
like The McLaughlin tartan has an old
tartan and a new tartan and there's
Tartans for special events and all kinds
of things anyway so we get we've got
dressed and got completely in the stuff
at the hotel basically so we were all
ready to go everybody's looking great
feeling great we did it was like a
wedding day it's a lot like a wedding
day because this is how traditional this
is how the Scottish people to dress for
weddings they do that's what the kilts
are for most of the time it's a formal
events and weddings we did put in a rave
party we put the kilts on backwards I
will say that until then we looked at
the picture on the internet and just
it's really easy to fix that you just
turn it 180 degrees so again it supposes
the skirt for men yet it's supposed to
start it's supposed to start raining not
only it's like
her seeking come in fanny packs yeah I
put the thing on him there's no pockets
in this well there's this thing dinner
you can look up the official name of
this I can't remember it now there's a
purse that you wear right over your
crotch and that's where you keep all
your stuff so a Scottish crotch so
Scottish men are the ones who came up
with skirts and purses for men on it man
come on the most manly men in the world
are okay with wearing skirts in person
so water's fine jump right in so I don't
know you'll find out what the most manly
men in the world are wrestlers but
whatever
there's Scottish wrestlers the
bushwhackers a New Zealand rowdy roddy
piper
yeah exactly no he's Irish I don't know
maybe Scottish he was a bagpiper uh you
said yeah a Scottish yeah so it's called
a sporran yeah sporran and so our R a n
yes
and so we've got our spoor ends and our
knee-high socks we can fanny pack look
like a bunch of schoolgirls it's great
hey and it's supposed to rain at like
11:30 based on the forecast in 11 30s
when we're supposed to meet the
photographer but okay so we pull up to
the the Newcastle there's the old castle
ruin and then there's the new castle and
the new castle like you can stay there
it's kind of got like a restaurant a
hotel or whatever it's also we're doing
McLaughlin lives the chief does it look
like an old castle uh the older the new
castle oh the new one new castle just
looks like a I mean it was built in the
1700s so it's still pretty old it looks
like a like a house but like a old
school house that you might call a
castle but not like stone spires and
stuff like that it's like the wind the
one in your Instagram that I saw that's
the old cast that's the old cast which
is still standing it's not just like
it's a ruin but it's still standing
okay so we pull up we we meet the the
chief and then we meet the basically the
chairman of the McLaughlin clan
worldwide who kind of took us around he
ended up taking us
he's the one that kind of took us around
to to to most of the most of the stuff
and kind of like gave us a tour of
things and would like give us
information it was he like was it was he
yelling in a Scottish accent no he
actually had a British accent yeah
because he grew up in England but he is
he is a he's a McLachlan so what was he
yelling like it was like about to go
into a battle no it's that's in the
movies link he's just pretty much a
mild-mannered well tempered man was he
in a kilt yes he was definitely in a
kilt and they were both in the
McLaughlin tartan he was in the old
school mclaughlin tartan the whole time
was the chief like had a gruff beard a
gruff voice and was he like gnawing on a
chicken leg I'll show you a picture of
my dad with the chief what and what was
his demeanor his demeanor is as captured
in there is with the chief which one
switch dude you're freaking they look a
lot alike
freaking looking like alike alike
McLaughlin's look at that they do look
very much alike and so the fanny pack is
more of like it's a crotch purse it was
a crotch cover looks like a bull scrotum
what his is made of a badger and my dad
and hers head yeah and my dad's is made
of just you know metal and leather or
something as you can see they didn't
like hug or anything it was like that
was as close as he was willing to get to
my dad in the picture
shake hands yeah of course okay okay so
we got picture the greeting Scottish
greeting we got pictures with him
he's a swell guy and a figurehead or is
he do stuff basically at this point it's
kind of like a it's kind of like a club
I mean essentially I'm saying okay but
they but they club like they're raising
money to restore the castle okay like
they've done a bunch to the castle but
it hits you up too and so in so many
ways yeah they gave me a brochure if
that's what you mean so
we begin like we meet him and then we go
to the old graveyard this graveyard and
there's a old chapel that was built in
the 1400s that the Laughlin's had built
there McLaughlin had built there and
then a graveyard with all these old
gravestones we find right next to each
other a Cowen which is my mom's name
Anna McLaughlin right next to each other
and he's like yeah the Cowens are
Scottish and so really well this is
crazy my mom's like standing next to the
gravestones basically about to be in
tears
she's like years before your daddy and I
ever got together the Cowens and the
McLaughlin's were together so it's just
I'm just like I'm feeling so good about
this validated man I did this right yeah
let everybody is coming up to me about
how great a time they're having yes and
it's just everything is going so well
what about the group photo was that did
that work - yeah that was because that's
the moment right there
oh yeah we we got mini mini group photos
which actually I don't have those on my
phone cuz there did you get some of like
just your parents yeah dude and did you
get some of like just your brother's
family just like it a wedding somebody
just your family okay and then some of
everybody that's a different company
yeah just the older boys just the guys
just the girls you started thinking
jumping up in the air when people start
dying these are the photos that will
show in your funeral type stuff some of
them yeah so like we did some with the
old castle in the background that we did
some of the new castle in the background
and then shoot different ways that we
had to get a silhouette we walked to the
old castle though there's there's
there's water is that the moat
that's the lock so lock fern is the the
it's the longest sea lock in the entire
nation
of Scotland so that means that that
eventually opens up to the ocean but
it's a very long the locks are
absolutely amazing beautiful this one
goes all the way up now what's under the
kilts nothing so I did say that I would
be wearing nothing but then the rental
agreement stated very clearly that you
had to wear underwear underneath these
kilts so how are they going so we didn't
they gonna lift the kill before you
return I did I you know there was lots
of talk there was license
and it talked about not wearing
underwear but then everybody ended up
wearing underwear mm-hmm well that's
most of it was we had to help each other
put them on you know what I'm saying
like we were like helping each other put
them on fastening them and you don't
have to be sitting there naked before
that happens so anyway for yourself
there's lots of great photos happening
everybody's having a great time and
again jumping in photo I emphasize the
weather got a watch that come down with
the kilt on it I don't think I can I may
sound crazy than I was talking about the
weather so much but listen it was
supposed to rain and it rains all the
time there and it was literally supposed
to rain all day and look at the weather
that we got from our photos perfect and
it just kept going and going and going
it's not a cloud of the there's a cloud
in the sky but not a rain cloud so then
we go to the old castle which all this
is very close to each other you can see
it on you can walk right around the end
of this right around the bay which is a
little bit of a walk for my mom and
nothing nothing too difficult so we get
to the to the old castle and that's
where I took my sort of epic photo that
I posted to Instagram that my actually
my wife took that photo not Paul the
photographer because I posted that
before I got Paul's photos back but that
was like that was the moment where we
were just kind of getting like it's like
here we are it's the old castle this
thing's been here for thousands of years
we've got the guy telling us you know
he's telling us all about the history of
the castle and how powerful this family
used to be the McLaughlin's basically
controlled both sides of the Loch and it
was a powerful family and now could do
anything again repeatedly my mom is
coming up and saying you know I couldn't
have done this without working out like
she said it more times than she needed
to now based on what I'm about to tell
you I wish she had to set it at all but
so we walk around the castle and we get
all the pictures and then and this is I
mean it's kind of it's a little
treacherous around the castle like you
know it's it had been raining it's
always raining so it's a little bit
slick in places and so there's like the
places that were like helping her like
step down and that kind of thing
and then we get up to we've gotten all
the pictures and it's time to go we get
we have a reservation at the restaurant
which is the investor on twitch is right
there next to the New Castle by the way
incredible restaurant like award-winning
I was like everything is going with
great we're gonna take pictures went on
this amazing meal and then somebody
somehow it gets communicated that hey go
around this way this is the easier way
out than the way that we came in like
this is like you've got a castle that's
kind of on a peninsula you got a path
that comes up to it then you have a path
that goes around it
we had come around it all the way so my
mom is on the outside of the castle in
between the castle in the water and now
we got to go back so somehow it gets
communicated that this is the easier way
but and so my brother is with my mom and
then my dad and then there's me and then
everybody else and we're walking I'm
actually kind of filming some of this
but then we get down to the like the
side of the castle and it looks like man
this is like these are like a rock steps
that it's kind of uneven and this
doesn't seem like it would be the easier
way and we're like it's my mom's life
this doesn't seem like the easier way
I'm like yeah it doesn't seem like the
easy way but they said it's the easier
way and and we're kind of like just yeah
I mean you're almost there anyway so she
starts taking a couple of steps down and
she gets to like sort of right on the
side of the castle and at this point my
brother and my dad and I are all it's
kind of hitting us that there's been
some miscommunication this can't this
isn't the easier way turns out later
what we realize is that what the
Chairman had told us is that this is the
easier way to see this side of the
castle or something and it got through
12 people through the grapevine somehow
it got communicated that this was the
easier way back mm-hm and then she was
basically already almost all the way
through it
and who who's to blame I mean me
my brother my dad we're all to blame and
I think at this point we're all just I
wasn't there we're all just taking the
blame equally okay even though my
brother was the one who was in the lead
and he is the one that is taking the
blame more than me which we're all it's
like it's it was it was this was a
mistake someone should have sounded the
alarm and I should have said this is not
the best way this is not the easiest way
let's go back around but we didn't none
of us did that so we're all to blame but
for what exactly
I turned my camera off cuz I was like I
gotta get down here I needed I got a
spot my mom because I got my dad and my
brother there and I'm like if she misses
a step she could fall into the lock so I
get down there and I'm like on the rocks
like spotting okay and then there was
like one more step to get down to
basically be on dirt I'm like she's
gonna do this she's gonna make it
she takes this one step lost her footing
falls down her legs sort of buckle
underneath her and then she immediately
Bentley begins screaming and she says I
broke my leg oh no and so I look down
expect screaming I broke my leg oh
basically crying crying she's crying and
so fifty things go through my mind the
first thing is I'm gonna look down and
see like a compound fracture and like
see my mom's bone coming out of her leg
yeah and I don't see that and I'm
immediately like okay I don't maybe she
didn't break her leg but I do see her
like one of her ankles is kind of it's
it's kind of an awkward angle okay but
we immediately begin to like get her in
first and now the second thing I'm
thinking is if she has broken her leg
how in the hell are we gonna get her out
of here we're like way out in this place
where you had to come down this dirt
road and and then we had to go down this
little path in the
this Rudy's rocks and everybody take off
the kilt we're gonna make a parachute
and so I think we're all kind of thing
we got to get her up and get her out of
here so we like you know what just let's
just stand you up so we stand her up and
she's like oh it's you know it really
hurts it really hurts really hurts I'm
like okay but can you with us kind of
helping you can you walk out of here so
she takes some very labored steps
putting most of her weight on us but
she's kind of putting equal weight on
both feet and then we talked to the
chairman who says I'll Drive my car up
here to the front of the place you can
get the car the closest she's a cow and
they married the McLaughlin and so as
she's walking like a hard and hotter -
she's walking like we're kind of talking
amongst ourselves and we're kind of like
a few feet away from her like my brother
and my dad have her and then Jessie's
like she's putting a lot of weight on it
I mean maybe it's not maybe it's not
broken and in like the nephews it's not
broken
everybody's like it's not broken kids
turned it she may actually just be chock
at this point you know let's just get
her to the restaurant because we got
this reservation in the restaurant and
this elevator foot and you know give her
some pain reliever yeah hope for the
best
right I mean you can turn your ankle I
can you can so so we do we get her to
the restaurant we elevate her ankle
give her some pain reliever she I said
we did not ice it because you know okay
you know how lock is like mr. expert
about lots of things
gets it from the best and so with a
sprained ankle like the latest research
apparently is that the immediate icing
is not actually what you're supposed to
do with a sprain I don't know whether
he's right or wrong
elevation is definitely a good thing so
we were like all right let's let's just
do this and have a good meal I mean
Locke did know about the way
site where you could take the design he
knows a patent and put them over other
countries and and so we we have a great
meal and I think we've all kind of just
talked ourselves into yeah she just
maybe she sprained it or whatever no
she's saying I need to go to a doctor
and we're just like where are we going
to go and you know we don't want to face
we don't want to face that potential
reality right so it's not your ankle so
now it hasn't rained this whole day but
it's supposed to don't face that reality
and I get it and it looks like the rain
clouds are really coming in okay and I'm
like we gotta get hurt we need to get
her into the car and we need to get home
to the hotel and then we kind of need to
regroup now keep in mind we're like an
hour and a half or so away from where we
were staying
oh so we get her into the car which was
not easy had to like take her down the
steps you know ended up being that
Jessie and my dad were the two best
people to do this I'm too tall like she
needs to put her arms on someone's
shoulders and I'm so much bigger than
her that like you're less of a crutch
and more of a crane yeah and so like
Jesse's like the perfect height for her
to like do that my dad is is five nine
so he's like I only get down so they get
her to the car plus you need to film it
yeah and I didn't film a lot of this I
will say I felt bad so we get her in the
car and I I'm not kidding two minutes
later it just starts pouring down rain
oh gosh I'm so glad we got her into the
car before this happened because this
was a really complicated thing mm-hmm we
start driving back now she's in my
brother's car the one he hit the van
he's driving and so I'm driving along
and we get up to we're following the
road and also there's a bunch of cars
stopped and this woman says like
Mathilde's us to roll down the window
and she's like the rivers bursted what
the rivers bursted the road
the rivers bursted yeah and she and I
look down and I see just like this
torrent of water just
barreling across the road like carrying
like large things across the road
everybody take off your kilt we're gonna
bit a raft and I'm like okay so I'm like
okay well did we get there's another way
there's another way out of this place
you know could just get up a lot of
speed so hmm I turn around and then get
the map out and start looking and
quickly realized that no this is the
only way out of this place there is no
other road
it literally is this or take a boat so
we Cole and I go back down and
disappoint him this point I'm beginning
to get a little panicked because I'm
like my mom needs to get back to her
stuff she's got like her medication and
you know I don't know what the deal is
with her ankle but it's getting starting
to get dark and a little bit this is
late in the afternoon and we go into
this like little local pub and hotel
area and we're just like what do you
guys think we know we got to get back to
here and they're like oh you don't have
to take the ferry like we have to pick
the ferry yeah I got I got a woman that
can't get anywhere right now and I got
12 people and two fans and it's no Snow
Fairy involved here did I mention I'm an
Internet so did you think about pulling
that car no and they're like you can
stay here tonight
Oh what okay turns out they had two
rooms which would not have gone over
well but cuz I was like we got 12 people
and so then what they're like the best
thing to do is just wait it out you
should probably just wait it out and
eventually the road will clear up but
then a guy comes down and says there's
giant boulders and trees on the road and
the estimate is that it will take six
hours to clear so you've got to take the
ferry yeah so I don't think I do very
well in these situations I think I did
okay I don't I don't think I panic too
much and I and I kept saying I you know
I was telling Jesse I was like if we if
mama died was what we call her if mom
and I didn't have this angle city yes
mama dies this is what we're gonna do no
Diane
named mama died this would all agree
let's go so if mom and I was not in this
situation this would be a bit of an
adventure stuck on a peninsula and
Scotland and having to take a ferry to
get back home but because she's in this
this state for her it's not it can still
be for us I feel pretty bad okay yeah so
we turns out the ferry is one of those
fairies you can drive your van on -
that's what I thought okay so I we go
down and we get the next-to-last ferry
for the day oh nice
it takes us across a lock to almost all
the way to Glasgow we it took us a long
time to get it we added like a almost
two hours to our trip to get back home
but and I call ahead of time to the
place I'm like because there's there's
no elevator to the first floor the first
floor in the UK means the second floor
ground floor means ground floor first
floor is the one above it and there's
only stairs stairs that kind of go this
was kind of a pretty rustic place we
were staying in Glencoe because
everything's rustic like call ahead and
say can we is there a way to get there
more easily like a luggage lift or
whatever you know you're gonna put her
in a yeah in a dinghy what's that thing
called we're the only not one of those
it would be electric
but they only there's a fire escape that
has just like two steps that she can use
so we go to that we get her into bed
that night and we kind of like take a
picture of the ankle and send it to a
doctor friend and the doctor friends
like yeah you should get that looked at
so that was when I was on the phone with
Jenna
who at the time was at Disneyland I
ruined her day and you know in
interesting that my brother and Jenna
both independently found this place that
was close by that like specialized and
they said the specializes in mountain
injuries ah you know because we're in
the mountains and apparently people get
injured and so the first thing in that
that next morning we take her to
this hospital and shout out to
socialized medicine because it was
completely free even for Americans it's
free for anyone who gets their stuff
looked at and what was your mom's
disposition going to bed the night
before and then next morning she was
actually in really good spirits she felt
bad and but we were like listen it ain't
your fault it's our fault
we're the ones who led you down this
path literally and you know what there's
only a couple more days here that and
basically all the major stuff we've done
it we got all the pictures you know
we're gonna just take you to this
hospital you lose the foot now you'll
have them in the photos and I and I was
just thinking okay we're gonna go yeah
we're gonna go to this place and the
doctor is gonna be like oh it's a sprain
let me wrap it let me wrap it in
something and then just give her a
denotes give her some prescription
painkillers or something I don't know
and actually I ended up Sokol and my dad
and Jesse took her to that and then I
had to take all the kilts back to the
place and so we kind of separated for
that it's like what are twelve people
gonna do to sit around and wait but we
get a text we get a text from Micah my
nephew you know but Mike is with me we
get he gets a tag because he was the one
that was checking his phone first we
were out and like the ankle is broken in
four places four places how I didn't
even know it ain't co-head four place
Eagles got lots of places man fly at
least four that you can break and first
of all you know my mom was in really
good spirits like she really liked this
doctor who was like funny spent all this
spent like five hours with them he of
course he did the x-ray and then he are
you sure he didn't break her ankle in a
place and then he put it or put her in a
cast with any x-ray - after the cast and
he wasn't happy with the way that it set
so he took it off and did it again and
got it set just right gave her some
laughing gasps she had a great time oh
yes she did and again this is all free
they'd hardly had to wait and the guy
was super competent gave her laughing
gas and but then he's basically like as
soon as you get back to the u.s. you
need to present yourself in an emergency
room because you're not going to be able
to get an opponent with an orthopedist I
thought you're gonna say you need to
present yourself to a lawyer and take
your son out of the will and he's like
you need to go to emergency room because
this is an emergency and they're likely
going to want to because he's not very
mobile and that other leg is not very
strong so she she it's really hard for
her to not put any weight on it she's
basically immobile at this point mm-hmm
can't put any weight on it and he's like
you need to get somebody to look at
they're most likely gonna have to do
surgery to get a plate and some screws
and a plate installed because that's
what you have to do when someone is
inevitably gonna put some weight on it
and it doesn't need to move so of course
at this point it's like I just feel
horrible right I and and whether or not
you know first of all I take I share the
blame with my with my brother and my dad
and not stopping and not going down this
path but I take more of the blame
because I know he was all this is all my
idea you know and I'm the one that gave
got her the trainer and gave her the
confidence that she could do anything
walk around this place and now she's
sitting in there with she's sitting in
with a cast you know we go to we go the
last two nights we stayed in a place
called broomall castle and minstry which
is outside of edinburgh which is an old
it's a castle that you can stay in it's
very cool and they thankfully they did
have a luggage lift that was not
intended for people but was big enough
for people and she was able to use that
to get into a room and I went and I
rented a wheelchair from a place that
you can rent wheelchairs from then we
arranged a whole deal about okay well
she's gonna have to have a greeter meet
her at the airport with a wheelchair and
then she's got to have somebody help her
get onto the plane and there's a special
chair that you get
I'll wheelchair that takes you down the
aisle and then you're put into your seat
because he's really not able to put any
weight on it yeah and just very mobile
so you made all those arrangements made
all those arrangements and then where
where it ended up is she was able she
was able to get an appointment on Monday
morning that she got back with an
orthopedist who looked at it and said
yeah we need to do surgery scheduled
surgery for two days later she got the
surgery and she's got like you know
people from her church like coming in
like building a ramp for her to like to
use a Whitley in the church had a
wheelchair and then they're like give
her like a special like giving her
basically a handicapped toilet with like
railings on the side and stuff so
everybody's kind of coming together and
taking care of her but she's gonna be in
this splint as the swelling goes down
for two weeks and then thinks she's in a
cast for like six weeks then she's in a
boot for four weeks this is the next
three months of her life basically
drastically altered my my dad's time
drastically altered we had to we have
forget we got a woman who's coming to
spend all her time when my dad's not
there cuz my dad teaches law still is
teaching law he's when he goes to school
we've got to have somebody watch her so
that is the situation now is that again
she's in good spirits she's gonna be
fine she's not mad at you no well if she
is she hasn't stated that she's been
very she is not there's been no blame
placed on any of us but I mean obviously
I feel horrible about this cuz I'm like
alright now I feel like all the progress
that she made to get ready for this trip
I feel like it's kind of undone because
it's like now okay well she's gonna have
to she's got to go through this recovery
process which who knows how long that'll
take I mean at her age it may not be a
you know she may take longer to heal or
whatever there may be another setback
and I don't want this to be the
beginning of her being more a mobile
than she was before the trip because for
me it was
like a win-win it was just like yeah you
know we're gonna she's gonna be better
for this trip but this will also be a
way to kind of get her into the habit
she was like I'm gonna go back to my
trainer after I get back from the trip
you know what she ain't going back to
the trainer anytime soon so yeah that's
what happened well listen it wouldn't
have happened if it weren't for you but
that doesn't mean that it's your fault
you know and I yeah so I agree with
everything you're saying but also
everything associate you know you it was
an accident you know accidents happen
all the time but it happened in the
context of something that were also a
bunch of positive and a bunch of
positive can still come out of this that
wouldn't have happened if it wasn't for
you as well so I mean she's got one hell
of a story I mean so do you I mean which
if you're gonna break your ankle this is
not a bad place to do it she's got a
great you see if you're gonna break your
ankle you might as well have a great
story to go along with it and she's got
not only a great story but a great
picture from just hours before but
actually this is probably a good time to
tell you another key piece of
information after all this you know
paying a lot of money to have the
McGlothlin to go back to their ancestral
home to meet the chief of the clan to
get their picture taken at the Lachlan
Castle to having my mom break her leg in
four places ankle in four places at the
Lachlan Castle turns out we're Irish
[Music]
or Irish what what what do you what are
you what do you mean we're Irish yeah
but we're not Scottish what what do you
what happened well I probably could have
done a little more research but who did
research afterward it's the wrong time
to do research well I will say that I
actually knew this before she broke her
ankle because my brother picked up a
pamphlet it turns out all you got to do
is pick up a pamphlet we were in we were
it was actually in Edinburgh we were in
st. Giles Cathedral
now okay that was a great punch line I
will say we don't tell me what happened
we don't tell me what's on the pamphlet
so Cole says hey in this in this thing
that says McGlothlin on it spelled with
an O kind of like how jacksepticeye
spells it which is basically
interchangeable oh and the NA it says
here that the gh spelling is from
Ireland and that some of the Irish
McLaughlin's came over many years ago
and became the McLaughlin's and so the
McLaughlin's
if I'm if I'm already a you every age
oddish McLaughlin was an Irishman
awfully this is where it gets very
complicated because if you it's very
difficult to research this stuff and
it's like first of all within McGlothlin
spelled my way you go back and there's
two completely distinct unrelated groups
and there's really no way to know which
one you're from
but one of those groups went across the
channel to Scotland and became the
McLaughlin's but then there's another
tradition that basically says that the
McGlothlin spelled my way can be traced
back to mcLaughlin but it's that's a
little bit less of a popular tradition
this is all this is very the records
were horrible one of the reasons that
there's all the different spellings is
because they couldn't spell somebody
would just be like what's your name
McLaughlin and the McLaughlin he would
just write it down and so there's
literally like 200 different ways to
spell it if you go into it like the book
of Scottish names or whatever and when
we were at the castle there was a bridge
that you could cross and on the bridge
were people who had donated money to
this bridge and one of the people was a
McGlothlin spelled exactly my way that
said McLaughlin like so-and-so clan like
and they identify with this with thee so
he's hoping the same thing you're hoping
at this point what I'm saying is that if
what you're saying is that your mom
broke her ankle for nothing well
something know now I gotta know now I
gotta take a trip to Ireland yeah you do
yeah you do
that's right do they have castles so she
that made it a little less special
listen man it's but it but ultimately
it's all what you want to believe well
first of all it alternately is all is
impossible to trace and can't really
know but traditionally speaking it is
most likely that's the McGlothlin
name that I have came from someone in
Ireland I can't trace it because we
don't have good our records are good
enough but maybe there's some Scotland
connection but it's definitely not a
definitive like I know I can trace it I
should definitely pay thousands of
dollars to send my whole family over
there so we can put on kilts and have my
mom breaker ankle it's not that kind of
connection you know that it's not that
definitive
it's not ankle breaking and four places
definitive wonder what will happen in
Ireland wonder what will get broken in
Ireland hmm had a great time I had a
great time he was a great no way yeah
you had live memories a lot of memories
a lot of good memories one in particular
but a lot of memories no one will be the
same and you could still be everyone can
be better as a result of this you know
with her recovery she's gonna be much
more confident in physical therapy and
to go back to this trainer then if she
would have just broken her ankle back in
it and she hadn't had it she hadn't had
the trainer experience you know a lot of
people just they flake out on physical
therapy and they don't believe in it but
she yeah once you experience the
benefits of something like that she's
much more likely to say hey I I want to
recover everything that I experienced in
preparation for the trip and leading up
to the one last step that if I would
have just taken a little bit differently
this never would have happened I was
trying to make you feel better but I
keep going back to that yeah I think
that V I completely agree that you know
any sort of tragedy like this is an
opportunity for without doubt you know I
think it's gonna it's obviously
affecting the relationship with the fact
that my dad has to basically serve her
you know when he's there is gonna do
something for their relationship that's
inevitable and the way that the
community is kind of coming around her
and showing her that they love her
there's no there are definitely
positives that can be taken out of it
and I do hope might mean my hope is that
yes she is going to make a full recovery
and get back into her training I just
don't want her to get too comfortable
and basically you know in a wheelchair
you know what I'm saying it's like that
that's my fear is that it just be like
okay well I I can't really do things
anymore
and I'm not saying that that's what our
mentality is but I don't want that demon
be a temptation so anyway that's my trip
in a nutshell Wow I have some other
things but we're basically out of time
that's really all that I needed to say
thanks for taking us on that trip Wow
still kind of reeling from that from
that left turn at the end and I will say
that my wife is the perfect person for
situations like this like she is so good
at talking someone through a difficult
situation in a way I am not good at at
all she was so good at talking you know
saying it's just a couple more steps
just one step at a time very simple like
comforting thing after the injury and
also that night we got home after she
had her leg in a cast and the next day
was the one we had slated to go play
golf at st. Andrews and my dad was like
well I'm not gonna go you know I need to
stay with your mom she but she needed
help doing everything she needed she was
needed help using the bathroom she
needed somebody with her at all times
and Jessie was like I'm not letting your
dad not go play golf that was like one
of the things that you had your heart
set on and I know he's feeling that way
so she stayed with her the entire day
that day didn't go into town or do
anything and stayed with her so
shout out to Jessie for being a voice of
reason and difficult times but also
watching after my mom so we could go
play golf because even though I was
thinking the whole time I feel kind of
bad my mom's back there where the with a
broken leg I had a great time playing
golf I mean it was it was a
once-in-a-lifetime experience and one of
the things I will I will also post on my
Twitter at read MC is I did a bunch of I
know a bunch but a good number of 360
photos kind of like what I did when we
did the one in here to show everybody
what it looks
like at the roundtable of dim lighting I
did that as we went around and it took
me a little bit late in the trip to
start doing that but both in Scotland in
England when I was in like places of
note I would like get a 360 photo that
you can go over to the site that I
posted them and kind of enter into that
world yourself including when we were
playing golf at st. Andrews just watch
your step yeah all right Rex in effect
short and sweet here get yourself a
fanny pack don't knock it till you try
it because I made that mistake along
with many Scottish people of course
there's many mistakes you can make I
mean you can plan an entire trip to go
to a place with your family and it'd be
the wrong place
get a frickin fanny pack hashtag your
vids get easier much easier let us know
what you think
give-give read some more comfort I've
done a lot but I mean can't hurt that
anymore and will speak at you again next
week
Wow Wow meaning anima to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]